economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela hablando con daniela
gracias por acompañarnos y entró en
vigencia en argentina un nuevo beneficio
de jubilación para las mujeres de ese
país de qué se trata
hola santiago mire le cuento que a
partir de ahora un estimado de 155 mil
mujeres que no han cotizado en las dos
semanas suficientes accedan a una
pensión de acuerdo con lo que se conoce
como un decreto de necesidad y urgencia
es decir que tiene poder de ley pero no
pasa necesariamente por el congreso- el
beneficio se llama reconocimiento de
aportes por tareas de cuidado y
efectivamente lo que va a hacer es a
contar el tiempo que las mujeres
destinaron a la crianza de sus hijos
como si fueran semanas de cotización en
concreto un año por cada hijo o dos años
si el hijo es adoptado o tiene alguna
discapacidad como nos lo explicó no lo
explica un experto de seguridad social
podemos dar un ejemplo claro es
importante una mujer que tiene 60 años
de edad en la argentina 27 años de
aportes se le van a reconocer si tiene
tres hijos o tres años que les están
faltando para poder jubilarse o si tiene
un hijo discapacitado o un hijo adoptado
más un hijo más le estarían reconociendo
esos tres años
estas tareas de cuidado están
reconocidas por la organización
iberoamericana de la seguridad social
por la viste y es muy importante que
esto pueda empezar a recorrer
latinoamérica para que sea reconocido a
los distintos servicios de pensiones y
jubilaciones del resto de américa latina
daniela hablamos ahora del sector
productivo las fábricas en asia
atravesaron una muy mala racha durante
el mes de julio que terminó así es la
situación es la siguiente el aumento de
los costos de los insumos y una nueva
ola de contagios por coronavirus
eclipsaron la sólida recuperación de la
demanda mundial en el séptimo mes del
año la actividad manufacturera cayó
drásticamente en grandes países
fabricantes
como china indonesia vietnam y malasia y
aumento en potenciales exportadores como
japón y corea del sur aunque la escases
llevó a elevar los costos en estos dos
países lo que más preocupa a los
analistas es que la demanda en china se
contrajo por primera vez en un año y eso
lo que quiere decir es que la
recuperación económica es más frágil de
lo que parece hablemos ahora de
venezuela y la escasez del efectivo está
llevando prácticamente a la desaparición
de los cajeros automáticos en ese país
claro esto lo dijo la federación de
trabajadores bancarios y afines que se
llama fe de bancafé trabanca que reveló
que en 2020 había 23% menos cajeros
automáticos en el país de 7500 quedaron
cinco mil 700 y este año podrían ser
menos en los pocos que quedan las filas
son cada vez más largas la razón es que
la hiperinflación y la dolarización de
facto que hay en venezuela hacen que
haya poco efectivo de circulación y esto
hace que los cajeros pierdan
funcionalidad la situación no es nuevo a
santiago en 2016 había casi 10.000
en la instalación y hoy queda un poco
más de la mitad y lo mismo pasa con las
sucursales bancarias en 2019 había más
de 7.400 el doble de las que quedan hoy
hablemos ahora de la unión europea que
va a investigar una adquisición que
planea hacer el gigante estadounidense
facebook bueno esta empresa había
anunciado en noviembre pasado que
planeaba adquirir customer este es un
servicio de software que ayuda a las
empresas a gestionar conversaciones en
línea con los clientes a través de
varios canales a los encargados de temas
de competencia del bloque comunitario
les preocupa que el acuerdo acabe con
los pequeños competidores de esta clase
de servicios y también que facebook
obtenga más datos de los usuarios que le
den una ventaja todavía mayor en el
mercado de publicidad en línea la
empresa de mark zuckerberg aseguró que
va a cooperar plenamente con la comisión
pero que considera que su operación no
daña para nada la competencia y en
cambio si va a resultar en mayor
innovación hablemos ahora de las bolsas
cómo les fue a los principales parques
del mundo en la jornada de hoy
wall street arrancó agosto en terreno
mixto en una jornada bastante irregular
marcada por una buena temporada de
resultados trimestrales empresariales en
américa latina subió la bolsa de sao
paulo con el mercado muy pendiente de
una posible subida de tasas de interés
esta semana y hablemos ahora para el
cierre de la cifra del día 245 millones
de dólares santiago con esta cifra el
fabricante italiano de autos de lujo
ferrari volvió a las ganancias en el
segundo trimestre después de que hace un
año cayeran estrepitosamente por su
puesto por la pandemia
los envíos casi que se duplicaron en el
trimestre 2.685 a nivel mundial al plata
para todo pese a la crisis de la
pandemia muchas gracias daniel as todo
por un momento siga con la programación
de france 24
[Música]